it was jeffrey jean in the confessional
let's see what he had to say for his
game with sam sebian
uh yeah so
very very difficult moment in my game
after he played
the move knight of six
which i think is a pretty strong move
because uh if he took on c3 there i was
quite happy with my position
after queen c3 e5 knight b3 and there's
some pressure
but after night of six it was
very very difficult for me because i
have so many options uh
first of all i thought b4 might be
promising
and if he
moves let's say knight cd7 i go a3
queen a2 bishop e3 and looks like i get
many tempos
so i think he has to take on b4 uh rook
b1
now if queen a59d5
uh
queen d8 97 and bishop a3 is probably
winning
so he has um
a choice between
queen c4 or
also interesting move knight ce4
uh but after knight c4 i think i go
riptix b4 knight d2 and rook a4
uh e5 knight c2 and
i think he has to give me two pieces for
rook after bishop d7
which should be better for me
but my problem was after rugby one queen
c4
then i need to
try to trap his queen somehow with
either
bishop a3 or
or moving the e pawn so if i try e3 with
idea bishop f1
i think he goes simply knight cd7 and
i'm not sure if i
have anything there probably not
so i was mainly trying bishop a3
but now i think he can go knight c4
uh knight takes e4 and probably bishop
a3 or 94 is
playable for him
uh let's say knight e4 bishop b4 bishop
a3 bishop d3
and queen a4 bishop c2 queen c4 looks
like
uh no more than a draw
so uh
then
coming back after knight of six i think
queen c2 looks maybe most natural so
that i have uh knight f5 on e5 but then
you can go uh simply bishop d7
followed by rook ca and then i'm not
really sure i like
uh my position here because queen on c2
is a bit misplaced he always has this
pin on the c file
so after that i was wondering uh if i go
queen e3 back
i might transpose to some other position
which uh
i think i
checked before with
queen coming to f3
uh but now
the issue was he could go rook d8
and if i have uh on queen f3 he goes e5
uh so
then i was trying to work out uh some
other ideas like queen of four queenie
one
but again it looked a little bit iffy to
me uh
after queen enforced a regate of queen
e1 i think he goes
uh maybe just bishop d7 something normal
and always e5 is could be an issue for
me so
in the end i decided to go queen e3 with
the idea um
okay knight of five's lurking so as i
mentioned i think rook d8 is critical
and now i think i have to place a move
like h3 just stopping knight g4
and
i don't think he has e5 here so
probably
he will make a move maybe bishop d7 and
then b3 and kind of the game goes on but
yeah just a really tricky moment and i
invested quite a lot of time there so
yeah
not so happy with what i found but we'll
see how it turns out in any case
thank you jeffrey and i think every
chess grand master have experienced
exactly what jeffrey just put us through